On Espn also just signed Tyson fury really interests.
So now you're not getting Tyson.
Do y'all do water?
I heard about that.
What the fuck is that about?
What?
What did,
what did Tyson say something crazy like why would he fight him again?
Um,
when he got robbed of a decision,
the last fight I heard that,
I was like,
oh,
is he drinking again?
Dude,
how about this?
How about this?
How about showtime?
My Boys,
they had the trailer,
they had the hype video ready to launch on Monday.
Tyson signed with these PN Monday morning.
No one knew.
Nobody fucking knew.
I feel bad for it.
Deontae it's heartbreak.
Deontae Deontae almost put them out in that final round.
You know?
And I think you can make a real argument that Tyson one,
the decision for sure,
but when you get dropped twice and get dropped one time in the most horrific
fashion,
I mean,
and now they say the fights not happening.
That's crazy.
It's the biggest problem in boxing.
So angry.
That makes me angry because there's different promoters.
That's why the UFC jumped frog the boxing a long time.
SORTA.
But I mean,
look,
that fight could have been made.
Do you think that may be Tyson didn't want to fight him again?
Nope.
I think,
I think it's his,
his handlers is his representation.
Go Dude,
let signed with ESPN.
Get a seven figure deal.
You can fight two bumps and then we'll circle back to wild.
Well man,
as boxing maybe.
I mean there's argument that that's a good move financially.
I guess it's heartbreaking.
Heartbreaking.
Right here.
Oh Dude.
I wanted to cry.
That's so fresh.
But it does open up Anthony.
Joshua Deontay wilder,
which is very sad.
But yeah,
nothing,
no time soon cause Deontae still gonna fight in May.
Maybe dealing white,
maybe Louis Ortiz.
Yeah.
Louis Ortiz is still fucking dangerous.
Really?
White's a motherfucker.
So then you know,
had Anthony Joshua be great,
but he's fighting Miller.
Yeah.
And that's a tough fight for him.
Big Baby Miller's got some fucking power.
You don't think so?
No.
That's a Madison Square Garden to right.
First Time Anthony.
Joshua was fighting in the United States though.
Yup.
When you find the United States have to out fuck Tyson fury.
Wow.
Brazil.
That seems like a fake name.
It's like he's a former football player.
Go Dude's name is breeze.
You call them Brazil.
Fuck Dominic Brazil boxing's in May.
My mandatory.
So frustrating.
However you got Mikey Garcia.
Earl spends coming up.
That's amazing.
We should do,
if I can pay him for that.
When is that?
March.
So.